jornada este nueva ante la que está a
punto de concluir aquí en las
inmediaciones del ex congreso de
santiago donde ha tenido lugar la
inauguración de la convención
constitucional en una jornada marcada en
las primeras horas por las protestas y
la represión de éstas por parte de la
policía con carros lanzaaguas y gases
lacrimógenos que supuso que varios
constituyentes detuviera en la ceremonia
afirmando que no iban a continuar
adelante mientras se reprimía al pueblo
en las afueras un tenso comienzo de la
jornada que partió con tres horas de
retraso pero que se fue calmando con el
transcurrir del día los convencionales
constituyentes eligieron a una mujer
como presidenta y no es sólo una mujer
es una mujer mapuche activista defensora
de las lenguas indígenas académica y
también de regiones una serie de señales
sobre el nuevo chile que se quiere
construir este será un chile
plurinacional y plurilingüístico marca
la refundación de la rotación de chile
con los pueblos originarios señaló
loncón al asumir su cargo la jornada
continúa con la elección del
vicepresidente a partir de ahora los
incluyentes tienen nueve meses
prorrogables tres cosas más para
escribir una nueva carta magna con la
que reemplazar la constitución de 1980
del dictador augusto pinochet